Non pas que les gens les plus religieux, qui s'en rappelaient le plus,
trichaient moins, et les moins religieux,
qui ne s'en rappelaient pas, trichaient plus.
À partir du moment ou les gens pensaient à se rappeler les Dix Commandements,
ils ne trichaient plus.
Même quand on a demandé à des athées auto-proclamés
de jurer sur la bible et on leur a donné une chance de tricher,
ils n'ont pas triché du tout.
Bon, les Dix Commandements, c'est difficile dans le cadre scolaire,
donc on a dit :
" Si on faisait signer le code d'honneur ? "
On a donc fait signer :
" J'accepte que cette courte étude est tenue au code d'honneur du MIT. "
Puis ils l'ont déchiré. Pas du tout de tricherie.
C'est très intéressant, surtout que le MIT n'a pas de code d'honneur.
(Rires)
Donc, tout ça dans le but de réduire le facteur de tricherie.
Et si on augmente le facteur de tricherie ?
La première expérience : je me suis baladé dans le MIT
et j'ai distribué des packs de Coca dans les réfrigérateurs --
des réfrigérateurs en commun pour les étudiants.
Et je suis revenu pour mesurer ce que nous appelions
la demi-vie du Coca -- combien de temps il dure dans les réfrigérateurs?
Comme on s'y attend, il ne dure pas longtemps. Les gens le prennent.
Par contraste, j'ai pris une assiette avec six billets de un dollar,
et j'ai laissé ces assiettes dans les mêmes frigos.
Aucun billet n'a jamais disparu.
Bon, ce n'est pas une bonne expérience de science sociale,
donc pour faire bien, j'ai refait l'expérience
que je vous ai décrite avant.
Un tiers de gens a eu la feuille et nous l'a rendue.
Un tiers des gens a eu la feuille, l'a déchirée,
est venu nous voir et a dit :
" Monsieur, j'ai résolu X problèmes, donnez-moi X dollars."
Un tiers des gens, une fois qu'ils avaient déchiré la feuille,
sont venu nous voir et dire :
" Monsieur, j'ai résolu X problèmes, donnez moi X jetons. "
On ne les a pas payé avec des dollars mais avec autre chose.
Ensuite ils ont pris l'autre chose, ils ont marché 4 mètres,
et l'ont échangé contre des dollars.
Pensez à l'intuition suivante.
Quelle est la culpabilité de voler un crayon au travail,
comparé à la culpabilité
de voler 10 cents dans une caisse?
Ces choses n'ont pas du tout la même sensation.
Est-ce qu'en se distanciant un instant de l'argent
en étant payé en jetons, cela ferait une différence?
Nos sujets on doublé leur tricherie.
Je vais vous dire ce que je pense de ça et de la bourse dans une minute.
Mais cela n'avait pas encore résolu le gros problème que j'avais avec Enron,
parce que pour Enron, il y a aussi un élément social.
On voit le comportement des autres.
Chaque jour, en regardant les nouvelles,
nous voyons des exemples de gens qui trichent.
Quel est l'effet sur nous?
On a fait une autre expérience avec un large groupe d'étudiants,
qu'on a pré-payés.
Chacun a eu une enveloppe avec tout l'argent pour l'expérience,
et à la fin, on leur a demandé
de nous rembourser l'argent qu'ils n'avaient pas gagné.
La même chose se passe: quand on donne la possibilité de tricher, ils trichent.
Ils trichent juste un petit peu, mais toujours.
Mais dans cette expérience on a aussi engagé un étudiant acteur.
L'acteur s'est levé au bout de 30 secondes, et a dit :
" J'ai tout résolu. Je fais quoi maintenant? "
L'expérimentateur a dit : " Si vous avez tout fini, rentrez chez vous.
La tâche est finie. "
Donc, maintenant on avait un étudiant -- un étudiant acteur --
qui faisait partie du groupe.
Personne ne savait que c'était un acteur.
Et il avait clairement triché très, très gravement.
Qu'adviendra-t-il au reste du groupe ?
Ils vont tricher plus ou ils vont tricher moins ?
Voilà ce qui s'est passé.
Il s'avère que ça dépend du sweat-shirt qu'ils portent.
Voilà le truc.
On a fait ça à Carnegie Mellon, à Pittsburgh.
A Pittsburgh, il y a deux grandes universités,
Carnegie Mellon et l'université de Pittsburgh.
Tous les sujets dans cette expérience
étaient des étudiants de Carnegie Mellon.
Quand l'acteur qui se levait était un étudiant de Carnegie Mellon --
c'était réellement le cas --
il faisait partie de leur groupe, et il y a eu plus de tricherie.
Mais quand il portait un sweat-shirt de l'université de Pittsburgh,
la tricherie a baissé.
(Rires)
C'est important, parce que, rappelez vous,
au moment ou l'étudiant se levait,
il était clair pour tout le monde qu'on pouvait s'en tirer en trichant,
puisque l'expérimentateur a dit :
" C'est fini, rentrez " et il est parti avec l'argent.
Ce n'était plus une question du risque de se faire attraper.
C'était une question de norme pour tricher.
Si quelqu'un de votre propre groupe triche et on le voit tricher,
nous sentons que c'est plus approprié, en tant que groupe, de se comporter comme ça.
Mais s'il est membre d'un autre groupe, horrible --
-- okay, pas horrible comme --
mais quelqu'un à qui on ne s'associe pas,
d'une autre université, d'un autre groupe,
tout d'un coup la conscience et l'honnêteté des gens remonte --
comme pour l'expérience des Dix Commandements --
et les gens trichent encore moins.
Donc, qu'avons nous appris de cela à propos de la tricherie?
Nous avons appris que beaucoup de gens peuvent tricher.
Ils trichent juste un petit peu.
Quand nous rappelons aux gens leur morale, ils trichent moins.
Quand nous accroissons la distance d'avec la tricherie,
d'avec l'objet de l'argent, par exemple, les gens trichent plus.
Et quand nous voyons tricher autour de nous,
surtout si c'est dans notre groupe, la tricherie augmente.
Maintenant, pensons à ça en termes de la bourse,
pensons à ce qui se passe.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe lorsqu'on créé quelque chose
où on paye des gens beaucoup d'argent
pour voir la réalité d'une manière légèrement distordue?
Est-ce qu'ils ne serait pas capables de la voir de cette façon?
Bien sûr que oui.
Qu'arrive-t-il quand vous distanciez les choses de l'argent?
Vous les appelez actions, ou stock options, produits dérivés,
créances hypothécaires titrisées.
Se pourrait-il qu'avec ces choses plus distantes,
ce n'est pas un jeton pendant une seconde,
c'est éloigné de l'argent par plusieurs étapes pendant beaucoup plus longtemps --
se pourrait-il que les gens trichent encore plus?
Qu'arrive-t-il à l'environnement social
quand les gens voient le comportement des autres autours d'eux?
Je pense que toutes ces forces agissent d'une façon très mauvaise
dans la bourse.
Plus généralement, je veux vous dire quelque chose
à propos de l'économie comportementale.
Nous avons beaucoup d'intuitions dans notre vie,
et mon point est que beaucoup de ces intuitions sont fausses.
La question est, allons-nous tester ces intuitions?
Nous pouvons essayer de tester cette intuition
dans notre vie privée ou professionnelle,
et plus particulièrement quand il s'agit de politiques,
comme 'No Child Left Behind',
de création de nouveaux marchés boursiers, d'autres politiques,
d'imposition, de sécurité sociale, etc.
La difficulté de tester notre intuition
est la grande leçon que j'ai apprise
quand je suis retourné pour parler aux infirmières.
pour leur dire ce que j'avais découvert à propos du retrait des bandages.
Et j'ai appris deux choses intéressantes.
Premièrement, mon infirmière favorite, Ettie,
m'a dit que je ne prenais pas en compte sa douleur :
" Bien sûr, c'était douloureux pour toi.
Mais pense à moi en tant qu'infirmière,
qui retirais les bandages de quelqu'un que j'aimais bien,
pendant une longue période de temps.
Créer autant de torture ne me faisait pas de bien non plus. "
Peut-être que c'était en partie parce que c'était difficile pour elle.
Mais c'était encore plus intéressant, parce qu'elle a dit :
" Je ne pensais pas que ton intuition était correcte.
Pour moi, mon intuition était correcte. "
Pensez à toutes vos intuitions :
c'est très difficile de croire que votre intuition est fausse.
Elle a dit : " Puisque je pensais mon intuition correcte " --
elle pensait que son intuition était bonne --
il était difficile pour elle d'accepter de faire une expérience difficile
juste pour voire si elle avait peut-être tort.
C'est la situation dans laquelle nous sommes tout le temps.
Nous avons des intuitions très fortes sur plein de choses --
notre propre capacité, comment marche l'économie,
comment nous devrions payer les enseignants.
Mais à moins que nous ne commencions à tester ces intuitions,
nous ne ferons pas mieux.
Pensez à combien ma vie aurait été meilleure
si ces infirmières avaient voulu vérifier leur intuition,
et combien tout serait meilleur
si nous commencions à tester nos intuitions systèmatiquement.
Merci beaucoup.